hey yo what's up boys it's jake and
today i'm gonna try something pretty
special i'm going to see a new game plus
one if my summon my fully upgraded mimic
tier summon can defeat the tree sentinel
that's been giving so many people
trouble so if you don't know about the
mimic tier it's probably the most
overpowered summon in the entire game it
basically creates a replica of yourself
it does a lot less damage obviously than
you do if i were to have flame grease
equipped on this character my mimic tier
will use the flame grease it is so cool
but let's see what this man can do
against the tree sentinel again i'm
saying completely out of the fight i'm
gonna do absolutely nothing or at least
try to come here buddy you got a lot of
work to do all right this is already
scary but let's see what we can do okay
let's see our summon go to work baby
oh my god he does decent damage i'm
gonna take my seat up here and to see
what happens my mimics almost got him to
half health i can't believe it by the
way the mimic can also heal
oh my god this is so overpowered man
this is crazy he's got him to have
health are you serious
oh my god he's actually gonna do it he's
actually gonna do it dude
he is going ham the tree sandal's got
nothing on this guy
oh he replied a bleed too oh my god
that's the tree sentinel boys he's got
it he's got it he did it do i get all
the runes from that too yep i get
everything from that fight and i
literally didn't have to do anything
this mimic is so overpowered dude oh my
god i can't believe that worked honestly
i think the mimic could go out and beat
the entire game if you wanted to i'm
gonna see how many bosses my mimic can
actually beat you know why that's just
so funny to me because i've seen so many
reddit threads of people just
complaining about how the tree sentinel
is way too hard it's just funny that my
summon can pretty much do the entire
areas of limb grave by itself if it
wanted to oh this is great man we're
gonna have to go to merge it and piss
more people off if my summon could beat
merget and maybe even godric oh man that
could be really really funny anyway boys
appreciate you watching the video and
i'll see you in the next one